[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well the mainstream media continues to
take a
certain narrative when reporting on the
fighting in
israel which we are glad to report as
we've been covering that
hamas and israel have come to a
ceasefire but take a look at this report
from nbc's richard engel today
israel kept up its assault on gaz
overnight
destroying what it described as hamas
military infrastructure
but pressure is growing on israel to
stop covering this conflict has been
challenging
unlike in previous rounds israel has not
allowed foreign journalists into gaza
hamas has imposed no such restrictions
many palestinians say
israel doesn't want more of the world's
attention focused
on the appalling humanitarian conditions
in gaza which is run by hamas
all right joining us now is host of the
report dave rubin
dave welcome back good to be with you
guys
all right well it has been really
interesting to see the media's coverage
of this
but we just heard from president biden a
few moments ago
talking about this ceasefire reached by
hamas and israel
i'm not sure if you got a chance to uh
hear it but what is your reaction
okay yeah well first off uh i don't
think we should call them the mainstream
media anymore my friend michael malus
who's been on my show many times calls
them the corporate press and i think
that's a better description of what they
are because i don't think this is
mainstream anymore
most people can see through their lives
as for biden's speech yeah
he accidentally called netanyahu
president instead of prime minister but
that's a pretty good gaffe
as far as the biden gaffs go i mean this
is just the same
old stuff no country
in the world should have to have rockets
indiscriminately fired into its
population
aimed at destroying as many people as
possible you know there's this weird
meme out there
that somehow civilian deaths and
military deaths and destruction
should be equal except no army in the
history of the world has ever done that
and if you
if you don't really understand military
strategy i mean if someone attacked you
with a knife
would you stop them could you just stop
for just a sec can i see the size of
your knife let me get a comparably sized
knife
to defend myself the iron dome is a
modern
miracle i mean truly almost like a
biblical miracle if we're talking about
this part of the world they are blowing
rockets out of the sky
and now we've got you know the hamas
caucus i would say aoc and talib and the
rest of them
saying well oh they shouldn't have that
because uh you know hamas doesn't have
an iron dome
in essence well if if israel didn't have
the iron dome
there would be more death and
destruction on both sides because there
would obviously be more on the israeli
side and then they would have to attack
even further so those images you're
showing there those those are miracles
every single one of those but every
country
is is placed on this earth to defend
their citizens
as they see fit and for some reason
there's only one country that when they
do
just that they're told that they should
just lay over and die and it's the same
country
that is habited by a people with a you
know 5 000 year old history
that's been pretty brutal and the world
hasn't cared that much so they're going
to defend themselves as they see fit
as i would grant any other country by
the way
yeah you know it was interesting though
as i watched that clip from the today
show and richard engel's reporting i
thought to myself
if you're just an average american
you're getting up in the morning getting
your kids off to school you're getting
ready for work
and that's where you get your main
source of news you think wow those
israelis are bad bad people
he talks about them assaulting the
people of gaza how they're relentless
and going after them i mean i if that's
all you watched if that's how you got
your news you think
israel is very bad guys i
every time i come on with you i think i
bring up the the reality war and the war
on truth well this is almost like the
most perfect example of it there's a
video that's on twitter that you're not
going to see
on uh on ms on nbc or msnbc maybe you
guys will show it on newsmax
where there's an israeli military guy on
the phone with one of the
owners of a building yesterday yeah okay
beautiful beautiful get your people out
we know hamas military targets are in
there and the guy is basically saying no
we want our children to die because it's
good pr that in essence is what happened
happens in this conversation uh golda
meir who was the prime minister of
israel in the early 70s i mean she had a
line that once
the palestinians decide that they love
their children more than killing our
children will have peace
the israelis don't want to be in gaza
there's literally no jews in gaza hitler
would love the place there were a couple
there were a couple jews there about 8
000 and they took them all out in 2004
as you know and by the way gaza is it's
not as if it's just in the middle of
israel just sitting there like they're
trapped
you know there's a border with egypt and
what did egypt do egypt bombed the hell
out of the border flooded all the
tunnels and made sure that nobody could
go to sinai sinai by the way which
israel gave up for peace remember that
so the whole narrative is completely
backwards but we we just don't have
people that tell the truth that's why
it's a pleasure to see you guys as usual
you know i do want to switch gears
because there's something that that
popped today or yesterday or other and i
i was like i'm glad we have dave rubin
on because i
i want his take chicago mayor lori
lightfoot she said she's not going to
grant interviews to any reporter that's
not
a black or brown person she explains her
reasoning
in a very odd way you know saying how
exactly is excluding reporters
who look a certain way promoting
diversity by the way
here's the thing that's interesting dave
a latino reporter for the chicago
tribune
canceled his interview with the mayor
after his
off after her office rather refused his
request to lift the restrictions he was
like hey
i'm not being part of this thing i mean
i this is literally
racism at its core yes it
is racism period and until people
on our side of the aisle whatever you
want to call this start
using some of the tactics that they use
on us
to expose their fraudulent nature not
because we're friends because therefore
she's a racist i don't care what color
she is i genuinely don't care i don't
care if the mayor of chicago is a white
person or a black person i care about
what their policies are
imagine this 2021 uh
2021 america where a mayor is saying i
will only be interviewed by black people
now let's try that any other which way
any other race
and we all know it's racist so this is
not reverse racism
this isn't some half racism it is modern
progressive racism that has completely
taken over the democratic party
please show me a democrat find me
somebody i'm begging people
show me a democrat i will start a
gofundme show me a sane democrat
who believes in the constitution who
believes that america is
fundamentally a good nation that 1776
was our founding not 1619
that's against identity politics that
can that knows up from down or left from
right i can't find any of them anymore
can you tell guys i'm fired up this week
yeah we love it that's what we love
talking to you
uh but it's such a great point because
if anyone else did it as you were saying
it would be racist
in this case all of a sudden it's not
from the left thanks for setting the
record straight here dave glad to have
you
good seeing you guys if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell